there's thousands of people across the  uk who've been watching this who who  love the game  and  um want to support the game but are  being extremely disappointed by um  cricket and the game as it currently is  what do you say to that and and what do  you say to people whose impression of  cricket now is  on the floor  i say  please understand that we're really  sorry  for what the experiences that you may  have been through through trying to  engage in cricket in this country we  know we've let you down  and we will we are going to fix this and  we're going to fix it quickly and we're  going to fix it fast because the  survival of our sport depends on it  and it's absolutely the core of the ecb  and we will work  you know endlessly to ensure that very  quickly that message is received  throughout our network  we will transform this game very quickly